on the 15th of September 2008 the US
investment bank Lehman Brothers filed
for bankruptcy with the bank holding
more than 6 trillion dollars in assets
its collapse was the largest in US
history the Dow Jones shed nearly 5
percent its biggest lost since the 11th
of September attacks and the ensuing
panic on world financial markets caused
the global economy to experience its
deepest downturn since the 1930s the
effects of which are still being felt
today the European response to the
global downturn was an unprecedented
stimulus plan worth 200 billion euros or
about 1.5 percent of the EU GDP in
addition the European Central Bank
slashed interest rates to prevent the
economy from sliding further following
laymen's demise European and global
regulators introduced new rules
requiring banks to hold more cash and
rely less on borrowed money banks were
also now submitted to regular stress
tests to see how they perform in a
future financial crash these measures
spared Europe from a deeper recession
and now form the foundations of a
stronger and more resilient economy